But wait there's more. We also have
data dependencies that can cause pipeline stalls.
Consider these two instructions, we add R2 and R3, put the result in R1. Then
the subtract instruction here takes R1 and uses it to compute R7. We say
that the subtract instruction has a data dependence on this add. In fact we can
have this data dependence, and there could be
another instruction that produces R8, that the subtract also
depends on. When we have a data dependence
that means that we cannot just do these instructions
like they were loads of laundry that have
nothing to do with each other. We have to
have the add produce R1 before the subtract
can use it. This type of data dependence is
called a read after write dependence. We
read something after it has been written and
that order needs to be preserved. This type
of dependence is also called flow dependence because
the data flows from one instruction to the
other. And it also called true dependence because
there is really a dependence as in the
subtract needs the add to finish before it
because the value doesn't exist until the add
is finished. So again, this type of dependence
is called RAW or read after write, or
flow, or true dependence. There are two other types
of data dependencies. Let's say that there is,
later, a multiply instruction that takes R5 and R6,
and produces R1. So that later instructions will
use that R1 as the result of the multiplication.
So for this dependence we say that's a RAW,
flow, or true dependence. There is a dependence between the
add and the multiply. The add needs to finish
first and then the multiply needs to finish. Because we
want the result of the multiply to end up
as the final value of R1. If we let the
add finish later than R1, produced by the add,
will be left in the R1, so subsequent instructions would
see that value which would be wrong. This
type of dependence is called a write after write,
or an output dependence. Basically the final result,
or the output for R1, is what's affected and
write after write simply because they are both
writing and we need to preserve the order of
the writes. This write should happen after this write.
The third type of dependence is here. The subtract
needs to finish reading R1 before multiply can be allowed to overwrite it. This
type of dependence is called write after
read because the write needs to happen after
this read, and it is also called
anti-dependence because it sort of reverses the order
of the flow dependencies. For reasons we
will see later, these two types of dependencies
are called false or name dependencies. So
we have true dependencies, which are these RAW
dependencies or flow dependencies, and we have
false or name dependencies that have to do
with overwriting a value that somebody has
written or read previously, or at least should
read or write previously. Now we have a
read after write, write after write, and write
after read dependence. So, how about a read
after read dependence, that's the only one that is
missing here. Let's say we have two adds,
both of which are reading R3. Read after read
is not a dependence because these two instructions
don't need to be done in the order of
that dependence. Pretty much we can reorder these
two instructions, they will still read the correct value
of R3, so that is why this is not a dependence. The second instruction
doesn't depend on the first one. It can be done before or after it.